bonjour florian filles pour merci d'être
avec nous cet après midi sur rt france
vous avez suivi un j'imagine comme nous
tous les événements qui se déroulent
depuis ce matin dans le 11e
arrondissement de paris deux personnes
ont été blessées deux personnes de
journaliste il sut une société de de
production
le dirigeant de cette agence de
production s'interroge sur l'absence de
surveillance policière dans ce lieu qui
était pourtant assez stratégique vous
vous interrogez aussi bas c'est vrai
qu'on aurait pu imaginer étant donné le
simple choix que ce sont les anciens
locaux de charlie hebdo donc du fait du
poids du symbole on aurait pu imaginer
que qui aurait pu avoir une protection
policière c'est pas à moi d'en juger
c'est pas facile à gérer parce que parce
que beaucoup de lieux à protéger
beaucoup de personnes à protéger en même
temps avec des effectifs qui évidemment
ne sont pas extensibles
ce que l'on voit là où j'ai une pensée
évident pour les victimes et en espérant
qu'elle s'en sortiront le mieux possible
mais sinon j'ai envie dire c'est quand
même dramatique de devoir commenter et
commenter une énième fois une attaque
islamiste un avantage puisque le parquet
national anti terroriste a été saisi et
on se dit mais voilà comme rien ne
change entre-temps on commentera la
prochaine fois encore une fois il y aura
nouvelle victime de nouveaux drames et
on en a marre on en a ras-le-bol voilà
on s'est dit qu'est ce qu'il va falloir
pour que enfin des vrais décision sera
prise dans notre pays te dire le drame
français c'est qu'aujourd'hui même là il
ya une heure la justice française a
condamné eric zemmour pour ses propos
qui condamne et l'islamisme alors on
peut être d'accord ou pas avec lui on
peut estimer qu'il est excessif parfois
outrancier dans certains propos
n'empêche que la justice française le
condamne le jour même ou à une énième
attaque islamiste et perpétrés sur le
territoire national
et là il ya 48 heures la commission
européenne présentait un pacte pour la
migration
il va encore accroître l'immigration
vers la france vers l'europe
hier on nage en pleine folie donc la
police c'est un résumé du drame français
pour l'instant fait un film pour l
attaque islamiste n'est toujours pas à
confirmer en tout cas pas revendiqué
ni confirmée par la préfecture de police
de paris vous parliez du contexte
à l'instant on ne connaît c'est en ce
moment le procès des attentats de
janvier 2015
on sait que la directrice des ressources
humaines de charlie hebdo a été menacé
récemment elle a dû quitter son domicile
précipitamment cette semaine une alerte
à la bombe à la tour eiffel
c'était un contexte de plus en plus
tendues et est-ce que du coup cette
cette attaque de ce matin vous surprend
non elle ne surprend pas et vous avez
raison de rappeler ce contexte mais moi
ce qui me fera si vous voulez c'est
qu'il n'y a pas une unanimité y compris
dans la classe politique française sur
ces sujets là on a entendu du côté de la
france insoumise
de plus en plus gangrenés par les
indigéniste son anti français clairement
et bien une incapacité à être clairement
du côté des victimes et un dire
clairement que le fondamentalisme
islamiste est un mâle nous faisant le
coup de attention d' amalgame la
personne de fait l'amalgamé normal cisco
ni à côté de six mois un français
musulman qui vit comme tout le monde et
qu'ils ne l'étaient qu'est loin de toute
idée était henry s'il sait très bien lui
qu'on ne parle pas de lui quand on
confond de l'indus l'hélice vous voyez
vous quand on combat islamistes en fait
ça ce sont de fausses excuses et je vois
peu à peu une partie de la classe
politique française tombée dans la
lâcheté ou dans le clientélisme
l'électoralisme et le pas faire front
contre saison puisqu'ils veulent qu'ils
veulent le mettre à terre avec le mettre
à terre d'autres pays c'est ça qui me
qui ne fait pas tous ces débats là en ce
moment sur les jupes les habits etc
sans vouloir appeler un chat un chat on
sait que ce sont des gens radicaliser
dans ses dérives islamistes qui veulent
imposer des pratiques moyenâgeuses qui
ne sont pas celles de la france et de
l'afrique française mais on n'ose pas
dire les choses clairement mais à force
de ne pas dire les choses on les combat
pas non plus florian philippot on
encore en train de traverser un contexte
particulier avec cette crise sanitaire
est ce que justement cette crise
sanitaire nous a pas fait un petit peu
oublié inconsciemment ce ce contexte
terroristes qui planait au dessus de nos
têtes
non je crois pas un mot non je pense que
je pense que s'il voulait se sont
dénoncés bien que la france ait traversé
frappé par des crises absolument
multiples et on sait que les problèmes
malheureusement un problème ne chasse
pas l'autre qui s'additionnent et c'est
bien le problème de la france c'est
qu'au bout d'un moment il ya tellement
de problèmes sur qui pèse sur nos
épaules et sur notre dos de français qu
on se demande quand est-ce que ça va
craquer définitivement parce que là ça
commence à faire beaucoup entre la crise
économique
effectivement la crise alité à crise
sociale et crise migratoire et fils de
l'islamiste la cuisine d'une
civilisationnel la crise des services
publics allaient tellement tellement de
crise qui s'additionnent que combien de
temps on va pouvoir résister et jusqu'à
quand le peuple français va rester bien
gentiment dans son coin et va accepter
de ne pas se rebeller ou pas se révolter
moi je pense qu'à un moment à force de
voir nos gouvernants et le gouvernement
ne rien faire ou faire mal
il va y avoir une révolte qui va y avoir
un soulèvement et ce sera évidemment
normal et légitime
est-ce qu'elle votre avis les services
de police étaient préparés à cette cette
attaque mais à d'autres attaques
peut-être dans l'avenir si elles sèment
de police je pense qu'ils se préparent
au mieux je pense qu'il n'y a pas de
risque zéro et qu'on ne peut pas dire
cette attaque là elle aurait pu être
évité je pense que les services de
police ils font ce qu'ils peuvent
à condition de leur en donner les moyens
je pense que le programme ciblé il est
un peu en amont
la france a pendant des années démantelé
par l'austérité s'il services de
renseignement je suis pas certain qu'on
les ait bien remis à niveau totalement
nous sommes un pays qui n'a pas de
frontières nationales ça c'est
l'idéologie européiste on en parlait
tout à l'heure c'est beaucoup plus
difficile de contrôler qui vient sur
votre territoire national alors vous
n'avez pas vos frontières ce qui est un
chaos incroyable vin dans le monde il ya
une dizaine quinzaine de pays qui n'ont
pas de frontières et il nous fallait un
peu plus sain de schengen et qu'il reste
des 200 pays du monde ont des frontières
nationales ce qui est normal
il faut avoir des frontières nationales
voyez donc ça ça nous affaiblit et puis
c'est vrai que nos dirigeants continuent
de
kiné avec les autorités de l'arabie
saoudite ou du qatar et des seins ça n'a
jamais cessé et tant qu'on continuera
copiner avec ces pays là dont on sait
qu'ils sont louches
on peut pas on peut pas être sérieux
dans la lutte contre l'islamisme
merci beaucoup florian philippon d'avoir
été avec nous cet après midi sur rt
frange rappelle que vous êtes président
d'ea patriotes merci beaucoup